JACQUELLINE FULLER: Well,
welcome everyone.
Welcome.
So it's a real honor today to
have Vincent Stanley here.
And for those of you interested
in buying his book,
"The Responsible Company," we
have it subsidized in the back
of the room for, I think, a very
reasonable price of $5.
So be sure and grab one of these
before you head out.
My name is Jacquelline Fuller,
and I run our Google Giving
Program here at the company.
And I'm just going to give
some brief introductory
remarks about Vincent.
So I think a lot of us joined
Google because we thought it's
a different kind of company.
And it's a company that goes
beyond "don't be evil" to
actually trying to proactively
use a corporation to do good
in the world.
And it's easy to lose sight of
the fact that that's unusual.
And that hasn't always been
a meme that existed.
But we've come to that standing
on the shoulders of
people like Vincent, who really
set into motion the
whole idea that corporations
can go beyond making money.
And corporations can go beyond a
few trivial efforts at being
socially responsible to actually
making that a central
part of who you are
as a company.
So we here at Google are really
indebted to the legacy
that he's created.
So Vincent has been with
Patagonia on and off for 40
years, since it was founded.
Actually just this week, when I
was working out at the gym,
I was making a comment about
some workout gear.
And the woman was
standing there
wearing a Patagonia jacket.
And she said yeah, just
like Patagonia.
You just feel good.
You might spend a little more
up front, but you just know
it's going to last forever.
So that literally happened
just this week.
So I think we're all aware of
the great products that they
make, and we love
their products.
We might be less aware of the
legacy that they've created in
the work that not only they do
as a company but the memes
that they've created
around the world.
So hopefully we'll hear a
little bit about that.
I got to read the book.
And some of the things that
were really interesting to
me-- and it is, for one, the
attitude of humility that goes
throughout the entire book.
In fact, he says--
didn't start Patagonia with the
notion of being a really
responsible company, but you
all were stunned into
consciousness.
And Vincent played a major role
in creating some of the
changes that brought about
a responsible company.
He also started an interactive
website called Footprint
Chronicles, which I urge
you all to look at.
They do things, for example,
like being completely
transparent about their supply
chain, which I think is really
innovative and a good prod for
the rest of the industry.
So we're really honored to
have Vincent here today.
Thanks.
VINCENT STANLEY: Thank you.
Thank you.
I usually like to start just by
reading the first couple of
paragraphs of the book to give
an idea of what the tone is
and what our--
the book was written by Yvon
Chouinard, our company's
founder, and myself.
And in some ways it's a sequel
to the first-- can you all
hear me way in the back?
OK.
In some ways, it's a sequel to
his first book called "Let My
People Go Surfing," which was
both his autobiography and a
laying out of Patagonia's
business philosophies as they
had evolved over a
30-year period.
This book is a little
different.
And we wrote it not so much
for ourselves, but for our
friends and allies and for
people who are interested in
going into business and for
people who are in business and
trying to do something
different.
So the book starts out "we were
all still in the earliest
stages of learning how what we
do for a living both threatens
nature and fails to meet our
deepest human needs.
The impoverishment of our world
and the devaluing of the
priceless undermine our
physical and economic
well-being.
Yet the depth and breadth of
technological innovation of
the past few decades shows that
we have not lost our most
useful gifts.
Humans are ingenious,
adaptive, clever.
We also have moral capacity,
compassion for life, and an
appetite for justice.
We now need to more fully engage
these gifts to make
economic life more socially
and environmentally
responsible and less destructive
to nature and the
commons that sustain us.
This book aims to sketch, in
light of our environmental
crisis and our economic sea
change, the elements of
business responsibility for
our time, when everyone in
business at every level has to
deal with the unintended
consequences of a 200-year old
industrial model that can no
longer be sustained
ecologically, socially, or
financially.
The co-authors have been
involved with Patagonia since
its inception nearly 40 years
ago, but it is not the purpose
of this book to retell our
company's history in detail.
This book, though it draws on
our experience at Patagonia,
aims to be useful to all people
who see the need for
deep change in business
practices and who work in
companies quite unlike ours.
Although we mostly address
companies that make things or,
like us, design things made by
others, this book is germane
to all businesses that offer
a service or to NGOs and
non-profits that want to treat
their people well and reduce
the environmental impact
of their operations.
This book is for anyone who
works, not just business
leaders and managers.
It is also for business students
and other young
people who want to engage their
best, deepest self in
the working life ahead."
And I kind of go on to tell
the story that we did not
intend to be a responsible
company.
In fact, we got our start as a
climbing equipment company
that made hardware.
I think that we were the leading
climbing equipment
company in the world,
and we had about
$200,000 in sales in 1972.
Every piece of gear that we made
had a burden to it, which
is that you did not want to kill
your friends or yourself.
So the quality control or the
attitude that we brought to
our products was
quite serious.
And the whole idea of Patagonia,
what we found that
the end of the year selling
our $200,000 worth of gear
with about a 2% profit,
is that we weren't
getting ahead very fast.
So we decided to create an
irresponsible company.
We would get into the rag
trade was our attitude.
We would sell clothing
to climbers.
We would make a killing.
And it would be so
easy because it
didn't involve hardware.
It didn't involve any potential
for hairline cracks
or metal fatigue.
And this would be our passport
to paradise for the future.
So we did.
We got into clothing.
We started importing rugby
shirts, heavy sweaters.
Then we got into the idea of
layering for the mountain.
So we were the first company to
produce polyester underwear
that wicks moisture outwards and
a layer of insulation and
then a shell over that.
A couple of things
that sort of--
we were not concerned about what
the environmental impact
of that clothing was or even
not so much concerned about
the social conditions of the
people that made those goods.
But we always had a strong
concern about the environment.
And I think that that has to
do with the people who work
there, because most people
were a sort of band of
climbers and surfers, who spent
as much free time as
they could in the wilderness.
The wilderness, for a surfer,
starts about 10
yards from the beach.
And the wilderness for a
mountaineer starts about a
mile in from the roadhead.
And I think what being in the
wilderness does for you, it
exposes for all of us who are
used to living a kind of
well-managed civilized life,
being in the wild reminds you
that you're not necessarily at
the top of the food chain,
that you can be at physical
risk, that you're in the
presence of something that is
more powerful than you and
then also more beautiful than
anything we can make.
And I think that the sense that
you get from being in the
wild is something that
cannot really be
explained to someone.
But it can be shared.
And a lot of the early employees
at Patagonia shared
this feeling.
So it was very easy
as we developed
the business to start--
the owners started to give away
first 10% of the profits
every year to environmental
causes.
And we focused on grassroots
environmental groups that were
saving a particular patch of
land or stretch of water.
We gave to people nobody
else would give to.
We then changed that because we
know that accountants love
to play with profit numbers.
So we changed the figure to 1%
of sales or 10% of profits,
whichever is greater.
And we've been doing
that for 30 years.
And we're due about $600 million
a year this year.
So we're giving away
$6 million.
That was easy for us.
And one of the things I argue
for in the book is that
everything that we learned
came very slowly,
kind of step by step.
And that one small victory
enabled us to think in a way
that would make the next victory
possible, mostly
because we could think
it possible.
So I'd have to go back to even
before we made clothes to a
major decision we made when we
were still a climbing company
to explain kind of the origins
of this and how
it worked for us.
We were known for our pitons
which, for climbers, if you
know that, it was the old
time-tested way of protection
while you are climbing
a crack.
You'd hammer a piton into the
crack, and then you'd run your
ropes though it, and it would
protect the belayer.
And each time that you
place that piton, you
did it with a hammer.
And then to get it out, you'd
tap the piton with a hammer
and draw it out.
And the problem was that as
climbing became more popular
in the early '70s, there were
only certain routes that were
wildly popular with climbers.
So you had hundreds of people
going up the same cracks, and
they'd be hammering in their
pitons, and then they would be
tapping them out.
And they were ruining
the rock.
They were ruining the climbs
that were kind of the basis,
and the love of climbing
that was at the
basis of the business.
So what we did is we published
a catalog in 1972 with an
article by Doug Robinson, who's
a Bay Area local, called
"The Whole Natural Art of
Protection," which pointed out
there was an alternative to
pitons that the British had
developed, these little
hexentric-shaped aluminum
chocks that could be torqued
into a crack without hammering
and then torqued back
to remove it.
And of course, we came out with
a line of these in the
same catalog.
And I think we had something
like 87% of our business was
reliant on the piton market
at the time we did this.
So it was a risky move, even
for a $200,000 company.
There were still 10 of us who
had families to feed.
And the business really
changed--
I'd say overnight, but I'm in
marketing, so that's an
exaggeration.
It was about six months, eight
months, before the
transformation was complete.
But our customers really did
move away from pitons and
start using hexentrics.
And it really did make a
difference right away on the
climbing routes around the
country and around the world.
What this did is it gave us the
experience that we could
actually talk to our customers
this way, that they would
listen, and that it would
make a difference.
So I'm telling this rather long
story, so when we go into
the next phase, we're in
the clothing business.
We're 20 years later.
We're quite successful.
We're doing about, I think
at the time, about
$30 million a year.
We are giving away some money
to environmental groups, but
otherwise we're a fairly
conventional business.
We open up a new store in
Boston on Newbury Steet.
And we discover after about
three days that employees are
getting sick--
stomach aches, headaches--
and they have to go home.
So we realize there's a problem
with the ventilation.
And we call in an environmental
engineer.
And he fixes the problem, and
says, here's your bill.
And we said, well, thank you.
That's fine.
But what was causing
the problem?
And he says, well,
formaldehyde.
And the formaldehyde was
off-gassing from the cotton
clothes in our basement.
And this was the first that we
really understood that our
softwear business, which was
supposed to be so much more
environmentally benign than our
hard iron business, that
cotton was actually a culprit,
that the chemicals that went
into growing cotton
at the time--
about 8% of the pesticides in
the world went into growing
cotton, so really a
pesticide-intensive crop.
And it's less so today,
but at that time,
those were the numbers.
And we were shocked
to find this out.
So we decided to commission a
study of the four major fibers
we used, which was polyester,
wool, nylon and cotton.
And then we were further shocked
to discover that
cotton was the worst of the four
fibers, that even though
polyester and nylon were
oil-based and had that set of
problems, cotton
was the worst.
There was, unlike with polyester
or with nylon, an
alternative to
conventionally-grown cotton,
which was to use
organic cotton.
And so we ran a couple of test
programs, and we made t-shirts
out of organic cotton.
And then we made the
decision to go all
organic in one season.
We had about an 18-month period
from the fall of '94 to
the spring of '96.
We discontinued the use of
conventional cotton.
We were a little premature.
We ended up buying all of the
cotton grown in the San
Joaquin Valley.
We were praying for rain.
Because if we hadn't had rain,
we wouldn't have had shirts.
And the interesting thing for us
is that in the process of--
there are two interesting
things.
One is we never could have made
this change if we hadn't
done the change in hardware
20 years before.
Because that gave us the
confidence that we could talk
to our customers, explain what
we were doing, and not lose
the business, even though
the price of the
clothes would go up.
Second, the criteria for making
the change was really
important to us, because this
was something we could do
something about.
And you know, the Google motto
is "Do No Evil," I believe?
"Don't be evil." We have a
very complicated mission
statement, but the second
part of it is "Cause
No Unnecessary Harm.
And the word "Unnecessary" is
key because it enables you, as
people in business, when you
approach a problem and you
know that there is a solution,
it gives you permission to
pursue that.
So we couldn't do anything about
making polyester out of
nonoil-substances, but
we could make organic
cotton, and we did.
And that was the second thing
that gave us a lot of
confidence in terms of pursuing
new activities that
other people hadn't touched.
We were not a special
group of people.
We were not very bright.
We were not well capitalized.
But I think that with this
background, it enabled us to
do things that other people
hadn't done before.
I like to talk about that at
businesses, because I think
it's really true for--
there's been a progression
since the organic cotton
change in 1996.
Our most recent kind
of big move was
about three years ago.
We got together with Walmart
and, issued on joint
stationary, which is I think the
only letter that ever went
out in history on joint
stationary from Patagonia and
Walmart, inviting major players
in the apparel and
footwear business to get
together to a conference to
form a coalition to evaluate the
environmental and social
factors involved in clothing
and footwear, to create an
index for designers and build
it into the company's ERP
systems, so that the designers
would understand when they
were making a choice what the
environmental and social
ramifications were.
And then eventually to take this
index consumer-facing,
which is still in the future.
But we want to get to the point
where a customer can
take the phone and run it over
a QR code on a pair of pants
and read what the environmental
health and the
social health of that
product is.
We invited those companies.
About 16 people came to
the first meeting.
And this was only in 2010.
So three years later, we now
have 82 members of the
Sustainable Apparel Coalition.
They represent a third of all
of the apparel and footwear
made in the world.
And the index, called the Hig
Index, has now been developed.
And the companies are beginning
to implement it into
their design.
I don't know how many years
we are away from having a
consumer-facing index, but it's
not that far, if we were
able to develop the meat of
it within three years.
This is huge, because if this
is successful, then what
happens is if you've got a third
of the industry adopting
this, the rest of the
apparel and footwear
industries have to follow.
And it has the potential to
make a huge difference in
reducing the environmental
impact and the social harm
done in those industries.
And these are two of
the old oldest
industries in the world.
Apparel is made--
I mean, the textile machines
are fancier, but it's
basically made the way it was
150 years ago in Lowell,
Massachusetts.
The only thing I'd like to say
before I open it up for
questions is to tell you why
I wrote the book, or why--
Yvon had his own reasons for
approaching the book.
But although I've been with
Patagonia for 40 years, my
primary vocation
is as a writer.
And I think that one of
the things that--
I had a question--
I was coming--
after 40 years around this
company, my question was how
did the culture survive?
In a company--
how had it grown from a company
with 10 employees to a
company with 1,000 or
1,200 employees?
How had the culture stayed
intact from a company that had
that $200,000 in sales
to a company that
now had $600 million?
And for a writer, the way to
attack that question is to
write about it.
And so that was essentially my
reason for working on this
book is I wanted to come up
with the answer to that
question, and then also write
something that would be useful
to others, particularly
to young people who
were starting out.
Yvon's primary contribution--
and it was an essential one,
which is to say, OK, we're
giving people--
we're talking about culture.
We're talking in general
about what we view the
responsibilities of
business to be.
And in some ways, these will
not be unfamiliar to you,
except that we do say that
businesses are responsible to
nature in a way that other
people might not allow.
But his primary contribution
was the addition--
he said let's make
it practical.
And so at the end of it,
we have about a 45-page
checklist, which anybody can use
to go down and look at the
various aspects of business and
say are we composting the
forks in the cafe?
Are we using LED bulbs?
Are we creating berms
for runoff water?
So what I'm proud of in the
book is this kind of
combination of talking about
our own experience and then
providing some very practical
advice at the end.
So with that, I'd like to open
it up for questions.
AUDIENCE: I had a question,
just on the manufacturing.
So I think--
I always struggle with clothing
today, where it's made.
I think it's good that it's not
made just in the United
States, and they're servicing
a global market, because we
need to grow.
People in other countries
are growing.
But then, one thing I love
about it being in the G8
nations is they have a lot of
great things in place, like
there's OSHA.
Just like-- if it's formaldehyde
in other
countries, well, they can get
a new set of workers to come
in, because they're so poor
that they have this
attraction.
So my jacket says--
I always struggle with when my
jacket says it's made in
Ecuador with US-based parts.
I feel uncomfortable
with that.
It's not just Patagonia.
But it's everywhere.
I feel uncomfortable
with that.
And can you explain your
thoughts and what you're doing
on where you're making things,
what kinds of decisions, and
where you're going towards?
I know skill becomes a big thing
in America, because they
moved all the clothing
outside.
Really, it's really the high end
has remained here, but the
middle end--
they don't have that
many people with
those kinds of skills.
There's a new-- one company's
just trying to get it back,
but they're not so successful.
VINCENT STANLEY: It's a really
good question, and I
can give you some--
the answer is a little
complex.
When we started, about half of
our clothes were made in the
US, and about half
were made abroad.
And we actually made quite a
bit in Hong Kong, which at
that time produced the best
sportswear in the world.
One of the things that happened
and it was actually
accelerated by NAFTA and some
of the other free trade
agreements in the mid '90s is
that it really killed the
American textile industry.
And when the mills moved
away to Asia, the
sewing tended to follow.
I've been reading some
interesting articles I
recommend to you folks,
if you're
interested in this issue.
In "The Atlantic," there was
an article about American
manufacturing moving
back here.
And there was also one
in "The Economist"
about two months ago.
And they were talking mostly
about what they call white
goods-- refrigerators,
that kind of thing.
And one of the things that was
interesting to me is that
companies that outsourced their
manufacturing to Asia
about 12 years ago found that
after about five years, they
no longer knew how to make
the refrigerator.
They didn't know how
to repair it.
By moving the intellectual
capital so far from
manufacturing, they
lost touch.
The other thing that's happening
is that labor
becomes a smaller and smaller
percentage of the cost of
every product made to
the point where--
one interesting thing I've
read in "The Wall Street
Journal"-- there is more
manufacturing done in the
United States than at any time
in history, but the number of
people working in manufacturing
is the same as
worked in 1941, when we had
about one third the
population.
So the manufacturing that's
coming back to the States is
not creating jobs.
It's being done far
more efficiently.
And there are great advantages
to that, but they're not
bringing work back.
The second thing in both
articles, they said that the
apparel industry is not
moving back here.
And that's kind of a
complicated story.
I think smaller companies are
doing some interesting work,
starting their own factories
in urban cities.
And the factories are decent.
They're not sweatshops, like we
had in the '70s and '80s in
the Bay Area and in LA.
High end clothing is actually
not made in--
high end outdoor apparel, when
you're looking at Gore-Tex
shells and those kinds of things
are made in about five
or six factories in the world.
And they're not in the
United States.
The capacity to make
that is not here.
So my sense is that eventually
the industry will gravitate
back to where the textiles
are made.
And the textiles could be made
in the United States.
But it will probably involve
some kind of revolution in the
cut and sew that involves
much less labor.
That would be my forecast.
And for us, labor is-- we're not
moving because of labor.
We're not moving because of the
cost of labor, but we have
to move because of the
availability of labor and the
availability of skill--
cut and sew factories.
It's a rather long answer,
but that's kind of
where it is right now.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming
over for the talk.
My question is slightly
similar.
I haven't read your book yet, so
you might have some answers
in there for my question.
So I'm kind of curious.
You were mentioning the trend
of the textiles being abroad
and how those industries might
be shifting back over there.
I was wondering with Patagonia
being able to build its brand
for all these years and be able
to start to implement
these pretty interesting,
socially responsible practices
along the way and communicating
with the
consumers you serve in order to
do that, I'm just curious
what advice you might give
to folks who are--
or similar companies or
apparel brands in the
developing economies that have
different types of pressure or
have different relationships
with the customers they serve
or the markets that they're
in, how they can also be
socially responsible?
Just any thoughts or advice that
you might have on that.
VINCENT STANLEY: It's
a good question.
It's hard to answer
in the abstract.
I was on a panel--
there was a big trade show in
Munich last week for the
outdoor industry with the snow
outdoor industry and apparel.
And I was on a panel with
somebody from O'Neill, the
wetsuit company and also with
these four start-up companies.
And they were really great.
And two of them were in Britain,
and a couple of them
were elsewhere in Europe.
And two of the companies
were really--
from Britain-- were trying to
source everything with "Made
in Britain" materials.
And they had very high standards
of quality and
craftsmanship.
I really, really rooted
for them.
But the ways in which we could
be helpful to them would be--
or the advice I would offer them
would depend on what the
company was making and
what its core values
were and all that.
It's very, very hard
to answer.
There's one thing I told them
that I have any amount of
respect for anybody who's
starting up a company now.
Because I think when we started
up in the '70s and
'80s, it was so much easier.
I talked with other old timers,
and we both think-- or
with the founder
of the company.
And he and I both think that if
Patagonia started today and
made the mistakes we made in the
'70s, we would have been
out of business.
It's a less forgiving
environment.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
When you started your talk,
you said that do no
unnecessary evil or bad things
that aren't necessary.
I was wondering if you could
walk us through the process
your company does to determine
if something's necessary or
unnecessary.
I have this probably false idea
that companies don't do
anything that they think is
necessarily evil, but maybe it
drives their profit.
And since you're a for-profit
company, if you're balancing
increasing your market share
by increasing more shirts
produced, but you're going
to have to offshore the
production of those materials,
how do you come to a
conclusion to say, yes, it's a
little bit evil, but we're OK
with that amount of evil?
VINCENT STANLEY: OK.
Forgive me for another
long answer.
We took out, about a year ago,
the Black Friday the year
before last, we took out an
ad in "The New York Times"
saying, "don't buy this jacket."
And the jacket we
featured was something called
the R4, which is a piece of
heavy insulation.
It's one of the most
environmentally friendly
pieces we make.
It'll last forever.
It'll last for decades.
It is made of 60% recycled
polyester.
Every product, every Patagonia
product, when you're done with
it, when it's kind of worn out,
we will take it back and
we will recycle it.
And in the case of polyester,
we can actually melt it down
and extrude it into new fiber
that's of equal quality to the
old, which is right in with
William McDonough
cradle-to-cradle values.
But what we pointed out was that
the water use to create
this jacket could provide
drinking water to 45 people in
a day, that it generated 2/3 of
its weight in scrap waste,
that it generated 23 times its
weight in greenhouse gases.
So where I'm leading is I think
it's not just a question
of a little bit of harm versus
less harm is that everything
that's involved in manufacturing
creates a great
deal of harm.
And it raises all kinds
of questions about--
or raises very serious questions
for us about the
nature and the future the
consumer economy.
I've mentioned I wear a simple
gold wedding band that
generates 20 tons
of mine waste.
The production of
each gold band.
So when we talk about making
products, once you start to
kind of pierce the veil and go
deeper into the supply chain,
the questions get harder
and tougher.
And you realize everybody
who's making things is
culpable in all kinds of ways.
So for us, the question is how
to certainly not to do the
unnecessary harm.
Certainly we can make clothes
out of organic cotton.
And certainly we make
decisions to--
kind of following the 80-20 rule
or depending on what new
developments are in fabrics--
make a product more
environmentally friendly.
Counter to that is the fact that
nobody wants a piece of
clothing that is ugly.
Nobody wants a piece of clothing
that doesn't fit.
Nobody wants to wear clothing
for outdoor use that actually
doesn't perform for
its intended uses.
So we've actually backed off
from time to time on the
environmental benefit of some
of our new fabrics, when it
turned out that those fabrics
didn't perform
as well as the others.
So it's really complicated.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
VINCENT STANLEY: Yeah.
Nice jacket.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
You made some really interesting
points regarding
the jacket, like you take so
many pounds of whatever to
generate it.
And all these statistics and
these numbers, you have to
have people who are
calculating them.
I'm wondering what does that
look like on your team?
Do you have a team of
sustainability people?
How does Patagonia go about
getting those numbers?
And just like in general, for
people who are interested in
that field, what advice
would you have?
VINCENT STANLEY: There's
two questions in those.
The first one, we
have a very--
until now, we've had two people
internally who handled
the environmental issues
at Patagonia, and
we've added a third.
And we purposely keep it small
so that we try and divide that
work up and make it part of the
DNA of the company in all
of the divisions.
We have not done a lot of formal
life cycle analysis
work, which is very expensive.
But there are tricks
we can do.
For instance, we can look at--
our underwear has the same
kind of inputs across 200
different styles.
So we can calculate the metrics
for that, and then
apply it to the line.
But what we're going to do now
is we're going to adopt the
Hig methodology.
And that has been established.
Nike developed a tool that was
kind of the ancestor of this.
And the outdoor industry
developed an eco-index that
was the ancestry of this.
So we'll use an industry-wide
tool, which is going to be
very useful for the consumer,
because all the companies are
dealing with the same numbers.
And that provides kind of
parallel information.
And then the second
question is--
it was an interesting
question.
I was talking to the
sustainability manager at the
Gap this morning.
And for people who are
interested in the issue of
sustainability, the main thing
is what kind of work do you
actually love to do?
Because we need people who
have an interest in
sustainability or responsibility
in accounting,
in manufacturing, in IT.
And those things kind
of come first.
The actual core set of
skills comes first.
And then sustainability
comes second.
Kind of the last point,
I've been
talking to a lot of colleges.
And until five years ago, there
were no sustainability
programs in schools.
Now they're in every business
school and in
every design school.
And this is going to make a
tremendous difference, I
think, in five to ten years.
But for now, most companies--
Patagonia, in spite of the fact
that we were started by
climbers and surfers, you
can look at the various
subcultures in our company.
The people who work in textiles
came out of Duke or
University of North Carolina.
The people in accounting,
they look different.
They came out of MBA programs.
And nobody had any
sustainability in their training.
So the language of each
profession does not have that
built in yet into its work.
And I think it will be in
another five or ten years as
these people graduate from
programs and then get jobs.
AUDIENCE: I was just curious,
when you were talking about
how a while ago you went from
giving 10% to 1% and how it
was very based on grassroots,
smaller companies, what is the
difference between what you did
then and what you do now
with the 1%.
I mean, I know there are a lot
of other companies that do the
1% for the environment
or giving back.
But I mean, there's just such
a plethora of environmental
organizations, grassroots or
larger, such a wide scale of
ones that actually give back and
ones that don't, I mean,
how do you even begin to
pick different ones?
Or do you hear a lot
of similar ones?
What's that process like?
VINCENT STANLEY: We have a team
that awards the grants.
We have a grant application
process, and then employees
elect people to a particular
team that considers the grant
applications and then makes
the decisions each year.
We haven't had a fundamental
change in how we give the
money as it's grown.
But I think now we're
at the point--
for a while we were giving to
300 different organizations.
And now we're giving
to about 750.
And at a certain point, we're
going to reach a kind of
plateau where we have to kind of
question and look at how we
give grants and what kinds
of organizations.
But for now, it's been focused
for 30 years on these small
grassroots organizations working
very specifically to
save or restore particular
habitat.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks.
I'm curious about your thoughts
on third party
industry certifications.
So you mentioned the
industry-led effort with
Walmart for sustainability
efforts.
I had thought these were a great
thing, and then recently
learned in one of the factory
fires that happened in--
I'm not sure if it was in
Bangladesh or Pakistan that
they actually had been
certified by Social
Accountability International.
And they had all the proper
certifications, which is a bit
disappointing, since they're one
of the ones that actually
seemed legitimate
and independent.
So I was just wondering if you
think this is a good approach
to having industry compliance
for social and
environmental efforts?
VINCENT STANLEY: Thanks.
I think it's absolutely
necessary.
But we work with the Fair Labor
Association to vet the factories.
But it's kind of a problem in
that you are relying on a
report card system, where you
have people going in and
auditing practices.
And it's not really systemic.
It's kind of based on a
kind of police work.
And that's how I think you could
get a situation like
that, the horrific fire
in Bangladesh.
It's also a complication.
The first question I had about
moving things offshore, the
larger your supply chain and
the more distant it is, the
more risk you have with problems
like this or the
harder and more expensive they
are to deal with it.
So one of the things we've done
is to really condense
from over 115 factories.
We now only deal with 45
cut and sew factories.
So that enables even our work
with FLA to audit more
frequently or to keep a closer
tab on what the practices are.
But it's not a foolproof--
third party auditing
is necessary.
It's terrific.
If you didn't have it, companies
would not have the
capability to go in and
do this on their own.
But it's by no means
the total answer.
The Hig Index, by the way, may
help because that includes
social as well as environmental
factors.
And so any time you're making
decisions upfront, you have
much more interesting and
stronger results than when
you're dealing with
a report card
situation on the back end.
AUDIENCE: Thank you again, one
of the things I really love
about Patagonia is the
repair policy.
So if my jacket had a hole in
it, the zipper's broken, I
sent it in, and you
guys fixed it.
How are you influencing--
from now, it's so disposable,
that you're going back to kind
of the old way, where
we fix things.
Are you influencing others,
and what is the business?
Is there any business
around it?
Why do you do it?
And are you influencing
other vendors to
just follow your footsteps?
Because I personally always
tell people--
I just told my friend today,
you like my jacket?
It's a Patagonia jacket.
And I said you guys--
there's something broken and
I return it and fixed it.
And so it is more, but I
get a lot longer use.
I'm not sure if it's cheaper
in the long term?
I don't know how--
but basically, could you just go
to the original question is
why do you do it and are you
influencing other vendors?
VINCENT STANLEY: Thanks.
First, a very quick thing,
if you talk about an
environmental impact of
anything that's made,
durability is a major issue.
If it lasts, if it's good in the
first place, and it lasts
a long time, you're going a
long way to pay back the
planet for the harm you did in
the making of that product.
So we like to make things
that are long lasting.
And then as part of a-- we have
a program called Common
Threads in which we look
at the four basic Rs--
first, reduce consumption;
second, repair;
and third is reuse.
We're encouraging customers if
you're not wearing a product,
take it out of your closet,
give it away,
or sell it on eBay.
And then the last is we take
back anything for recycling.
So repair is an important
function.
It's important for us as
designers to make things that
are repairable.
And there have been times we've
made some outerwear with
zippers that's kind
of tough to redo.
We've reduced the repair time
from the customer to our Reno
warehouse to make
sure that people
pursue that as an option.
Because we found that people,
when we had an eight week
turnaround for repairs, we'd
end up giving somebody a
jacket rather than making them
wait that long, if it was a
new product that
had a problem.
AUDIENCE: I think that's really
great, especially like
the eBay one.
I think that's really
innovative.
It's like if you look at other
vendors, they don't support
reselling your good on eBay.
They say, well, no, you've
got to buy it from
the store brand new.
You can't buy on-- they don't
support a secondary market.
And I thought that
was really bold.
And I think it is really great
for sustainability.
VINCENT STANLEY: Thanks.
We're starting in our stores.
We have a second-hand aisle in
the Portland store that we
started called the
second home.
AUDIENCE: So I guess I'll wrap
it up with one final question.
So you're looking at Patagonia
as a company, how do you
promote and continue your
culture as you expand?
And how do you make sure that
employees can work on these
interesting projects, like you
mentioned the Common Threads
initiative?
VINCENT STANLEY: I think--
I haven't had a chance to talk
to a lot of people here, but I
know that you have your program
about taking 20% of
the time to work on projects
that you feel personally
interested in.
And we don't have
a formal program
like that at Patagonia.
But I think that there's a
strong sense in the culture
that that's possible, that
people can work on something
that's very close to them, that
they'll find allies, and
that they'll get support.
So I think that's an important
element in
keeping the culture going.
The second thing that's,
I think, very
important for us is--
I was talking to some
folks at lunch.
There was a time when the
Chouinards, who own all the
stock, I think, were
ready to sell.
And the advantage to them is
they could have solved the
company for x number of
dollars, created an
environmental foundation, and
given away a lot more money
every year than we do
now as a company.
But part of the reason they
wanted to keep the company is
because we can be an example.
If we function as a
profit-making company and can
be respected by other companies
for the work we do
as a business, and at the same
time we choose to do certain
things because we get interested
in them first, or
we're motivated to do them for
reasons that have nothing to
do with profit, but we can show
that a business can do
it, that's a tremendous
advantage.
And that's an advantage you
don't get from just having a
foundation.
So that's really critical
to our mission.
So the first part is build the
best product, cause no
unnecessary harm.
And the last is use business
to inspire and implement
solutions to the environmental
crisis.
And so that's why we're
in business.
And I think as long as we stay
focused that way, we won't
have any trouble attracting and
retaining good folks, even
though our volleyball courts
are not as nice as yours.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Well, on that note, Vincent,
thank you very much for
speaking with us today.
VINCENT STANLEY: Thank
you very much.
Thanks for your questions.